in many parts of the u.s long lines at
koba testing sites are back and rapid
tests can be hard to get thanks to the
emergence of the new omicron variant in
response the binding administration
recently said it plans to increase
access to testing sites and free at-home
testing i'm announcing today
the federal government will purchase one
half billion that's not million billion
with a b
additional at home rapid test with
delivery starting in january the move
appears to be a shift in strategy for
the white house earlier this month press
secretary jen sackey dismissed the idea
of sending rabbit tests to every
american how much does that cost and
then what happens after that so why has
reliable and fast access in the u.s
continue to be an issue two years into
the pandemic let's start with the
science there are two main kinds of
tests both of which still work on
omicron the first kind are pcr tests
these look for the viruses genetic
information or rna depending on demand
it can take anywhere from several hours
to a day or two to get your results part
of the wait time has to do with how the
tests work the virus's genetic
information needs to be amplified or
copied and that takes time to run them a
trained professional often needs to swap
your nose to get the sample and with
pharmacies already experiencing worker
shortages needing somebody to actually
administer the tests adds strain to the
system health experts say that knowing
there will be long waits for tests and
results can lead to even more issues to
start it can discourage people from
going to get tested if someone in line
actually has covered the longer they
wait the more likely it is they could
expose someone and finally people may be
less likely to isolate while waiting for
results especially if they don't have
symptoms all that gives the virus plenty
of opportunity to spread and mutate so
those are some of the problems we're
seeing with pcr testing some of which
aren't all that different from what we
saw in the spring of 2020 but now we
have another kind of test at home rapid
tests those are the ones that the biden
administration is ordering up these
tests look for viral proteins or
antigens they work a bit like pregnancy
tests giving results in a matter of
minutes but as my co-worker brianna
abbott told me you know we were really
really vaccine focused for a really long
time and it is now clear that you know
that's not going to be the only thing we
need other tools in our toolbox this is
the first time rapid tests have been
sold to consumers at this scale and so
you really started to see the tests hit
the shelves in
you know march and april of this year
and even then there wasn't a lot of
interest when when they first started
hitting the shelves in earnest because
you know that's when the vaccines were
rolling out health officials
de-emphasized testing saying most
vaccinated people didn't need to get
tested in most situations and production
slowed down but then came delta and
cases started surging and even
vaccinated people got infected the
government pledged billions to make
rapid tests more widely available and
cheaper in part by ramping up production
fast forward to today the administration
is opening up more free federal testing
sites where you can get a pcr test and
mailing 500 million rapid tests out to
americans for free that practice has
been standard in some european countries
for months some health experts said the
move may have come too late 500 million
tests might sound big but at a
population of more than 330 million in
the u.s that's fewer than two tests per
person and health experts told me that
people should really be testing two
times a week especially if they're going
to work or social gatherings
in the past testing backlogs of ease
when people started to feel like life
was going back to a pre-pandemic normal
and demand went down but that can create
the potential for outbreaks that go
undetected starting the cycle again
that's why health experts have stressed
for months the continued importance of
routine testing especially with rapid
tests even as cases are trending down if
you found this video useful don't forget
to hit subscribe and if you're
interested in learning more about at
home testing or omicron check out our
other videos thanks for watching e dense
you